foreign
let's go to Emily in Austin Texas what's
up Emily
hey wow
like real life oh it's real life it's
about to get rich what's up
hey okay let's do this I guess what are
you nervous about
everything I don't know I didn't think I
was and then all of a sudden here it is
I've had this effect on people even when
I was dating like I didn't date in
middle school but when I had like a
girlfriend
I always made everybody nervous I think
I just did that for you I don't love it
for me I think it was weird okay go
ahead go ahead okay
um so I'm gonna read my question because
I swirl off so you might have to like
roll me back in a little bit all right
um but my question is how do I let go of
my extreme fear of dying alone so I
guess my biggest fear is like this
unknown that comes with age like what if
I get Alzheimer am I just gonna sit in a
nursing home Forever Alone
um I've been divorced twice and I'm
scared to leave my current relationships
that's very toxic Because deep down I'm
almost 40 and I don't have kids and I
can't have kids and I feel like this is
my last chance for a family
foreign
this is one of those rare calls that
probably more than anything I could say
if you and I were just
sitting down talking somewhere
um
I would just sit in silence for about 30
seconds and then I would ask your
permission if I could give you a hug
and I would hug you to the point that it
got a little bit awkward and then the
point where your shoulders could drop
and you could feel that I love you
and there's not something wrong with you
because there's not
yeah
what happened in your first marriage
um well I was really young nobody
I mean
so growing up I always just wanted to
have a family I I did have siblings but
um they were older and so I kind of grew
up as an only child and so I was 18 and
a situation presented itself to get
married to someone with two tiny little
kids and so I did and
um I raised them for five years I was
their mom
and then he
um cheated on me and left and moved to a
different state and so that just kind of
ended abruptly
[Music]
um
sit right there
I don't want to blow by how huge that is
yeah
like you were 18 years old you were
still a baby and then
you had an insta family
and
this was your this was your life this
was your family for five years
did you give up College in your dreams
for other things for this one path
oh yeah absolutely I was a crazy
crazy person who had my whole life
mapped out you know because we don't
know any better and yeah just throw it
all to it
to these babies because they were mine
and
you didn't just get left romantically
which is brutal you didn't just get
cheated on which is brutal
this cat stole your family
yeah he's all my babies
I took your heart with him right
absolutely I was very empty for a long
time yeah
all right so then what happened to the
next one
eloped and
um
that's why not
and he was a soldier has had a lot of
PTSD
got into some really heavy alcohol
addiction
um to where he was going to rehab when
three have a couple times did a um
inpatient where I had to take him like
to the hospital to detox a few times and
then
uh sent to like a three-month rehab and
during that say he just decided he
wanted a life of Solitude
so three years into our marriage we just
didn't have a marriage anymore
I don't have to tell you how damaging
and hard it is to be married to someone
who's an alcoholic
yeah that was crazy because they're
staring you in the face but they're not
there
absolutely and you're making love to
them but they're not there and you're
trying to talk about the future and
they're not there and it makes you feel
it makes you feel insane
yeah
and then they leave you
right right
the person is there to do anything and
everything and I'm one of those ride or
die people like I would I would have
stayed with my first husband after
cheating I would have stayed with him
through
Emily why
I don't know why don't you like her I
don't know how to I don't know that's
fair that's fair I'll give you that
and then what about this person you're
with now
it's kind of uh
starting to remind me a little bit of my
last relationship with like a lot of the
PTSD stuff starting to to trickle in
um
he's a police officer with you know been
a soldier and wore stuff coming up but
also just it's smothering like it's too
much constant like phone calls and
texting and this and that and it's like
it's overwhelming it's just too much and
so we don't know how to communicate well
with each other have you sat down and
said hey this is a lot
absolutely and he just says I don't
really care what you think this is how
I'm Gonna Roll
yeah it's kind of been like hey I need a
boundary of I drive to work for 10
minutes like I just need to not talk to
you for those 10 minutes or I can text
you that I'm on my way home but I need
to be able to just drive home for those
10 minutes and just decompress and and
then it's a thing it's always a thing
like can you please not call me 15 times
when I'm at work because I think there's
an emergency when well I just needed to
know if you need to take from the
grocery store you know it's it's a lot
it's a lot
and I'm used to being alone and and by
myself and this is you know the first
relationship I've been in for four or
five years and I it's too much like I
just
you you know your body better than
anybody
yeah over 40 years you've been
conditioned strongly to not trust that
body
yeah and you're either wide open
or you are shut them down
yep
and my dream for you would be to be wide
open
for Emily
so the
it's like
I was a licensed therapist and we were
sitting down talking
um which I'm not
I would go you know what let's do it
anyway we can do it we got a few minutes
go to the end go all the way to the end
give me a scale on one to a hundred how
healthy you are 100 being like you've
got to be kidding me super healthy and
then one being like
I'm mainly
give me 20.
all right so 20. so let's say you're 75
and you're at the end of your life okay
absolutely maybe 70. maybe 70. yeah I've
got some miles yeah I uh I used I
snorted brown sugar off the counter so I
I've got a lot of miles on my body so
um back when I was a kid so
um
I have so many questions about that but
we can trust me I had a problem I used
to eat it without a spoon uh anyway
um
so you're 75.
and you're in a nursing home and you're
all alone
describe that for me
I just think that you're just lost like
describe before you're thinking about it
I want you to describe it put yourself
there
just sitting alone in a chair just
sitting there where does that picture
someone else around you
I think with my um grandpa when he had
Alzheimer's we had him even in our home
but he would just sit there just alone
and
nobody really like
I see other families and you know uh
grandparents or whatever and you're
always taking care of each other and
there's that love there but
there's like I don't have any of that
and so I just picked her at the end of
the day just being alone like in a chair
just all by yourself getting changed by
someone that you don't know you know
what I mean just sad it just it looks
sad yeah
yeah I don't think that's end of life I
think that's right now
I think you're a good anxious person
like me and the rest of us that can
project our brains will spin UPS
narratives and stories that aren't true
into the future that we can worry about
in the present because I just that
allows us to not to avoid what we're
experiencing right now
yeah but you have a guy that texts you
400 times a day and you are completely
and totally alone
yeah
and you've gone all in twice on two
different people and they've left you
one for a bottle and one for who knows
what
and that feeling of I'm just sitting
here in a chair is right now
Fair
yeah
so here's my question
you can continue what I what you just
described to me in a few minutes I'm
sure you and I could could hang out for
a couple hours and you can tell me the
full story but in just a few minutes it
looks like it has been a slow
collapsing of
Emily
over the period of
20 or so years
and probably for honest and got into
your childhood there's probably some of
that there too
oh yeah
I could be a weekly segment if you'd
like
it's time for time with Emily
um
so we could go through all that and I
think it'd be worthy to go through all
that but we're here
right and so
let me just let me cast a vision for you
as though you're my sister
okay you're my friend
you can't go back and change that stuff
that happened even though it shaped you
in a profound way
the question I want to ask you is are
you going to continue to think I'm only
worth this much until you just can't
take it or they can't take it and they
they leave or you leave but I think
you're too stubborn I think you're too
right or die to ever leave I think you'd
marry somebody who's abusive and
controlling
because ride or die
and
you can do that or
you can live wide open not for some some
person who's going to come in and rescue
you
but for you
so my question would be
what will you have done when you're
sitting in this rocking chair and you're
75 years old
well you have gone skydiving or got
another graduate degree or play checkers
with old folks and all folks home every
Saturday or serve your local church or
try to would you will you have done that
will that be the story of your life
or will it be these hyper intense
relationships where you get set on fire
followed by half a decade of
isolation
yes that's where we are in one of the
you get to pick both Avenues
[Applause]
do you have a gang of like women there
in Austin that you hang with
where I came from because you'll judge
me but I
often recently from where
California I'm not judging you dude I
was just in Hollywood a few months ago
it's amazing it's the one of those
beautiful places on the I walked outside
like at 5 30 in the morning which is
noon for me back here not really but uh
let's go get some coffee and I just
remember stopping and laughing I was
like oh this is why everyone on the
planet wants to live here it was
incredible I don't judge you good for
you I mean it's good weather but yeah
you're a Texan so I'm sure you're aware
I mean we're not we're superior but I
mean I'm not gonna judge you right right
okay so
here's a beautiful moment
and I usually don't like this kind of
language but I'm going to do it anyway
this is an either or moment for you
you're almost 40 right
yeah okay I made the same Journey
39 and a half I moved to Nashville
marriage barely barely hanging on
um
no friends maybe one or two like that I
had colleagues right some people that
I'd known that we weren't super close
yet or we had been close and not anymore
but but
I had a choice to make
I'm either gonna go all in and be weird
and just go make friends and invite
people over from work and take people to
lunch and put in my budget like this is
just I go to lunch a lot or I have lots
of coffee with people or I say yes to
every invitation to whatever
um you can do that
or you can just circle the wagons and go
home every night and watch wait for the
next Ted lasso season to start
and my challenge to you is looking back
over the last 20 years of your life
the Ted lasso route hasn't worked
would you be willing to try something
crazy and different for Emily now
I guess it's time
I don't know another path
or be that weird person at the gym that
asks people to hang out after meeting
them at the gym
I don't know like what are you into I
don't know what you do but man
I mean I'm only out of 20 so I guess I
need to get something
but you know what I mean yeah
and he here's it's it feels to me like
you have a very anxious life
can I run through a couple things with
you and you just say yay or nay or give
me like some quick data points
do you owe money
yes a lot
yep okay not a lot of friends
what's your calendar look like
empty your chaos
I fill it up with work okay so you don't
do heroin but you do work
correct yes what's your job
I am a director at a preschool
ah so you are
a crazy person yes no you're you're a
saint is what you are you're an absolute
saint but you also have to deal with
overzilla's parents 24 7 365. and you
have to deal with preschoolers and you
have to deal with teachers which all of
that is a lot
right but at least you didn't have to do
that during covet in California and you
did right so
I want you to understand your body is
doing the best it can to protect you
it's just doing its job
and you've created an anxious Universe
for your body to live in and it's really
hard every alarm you've got is going off
and they should be
and so if you reverse engineer this
thing
and say where or places I can begin to
get Freedom back in my life
so I give my body a fighting chance to
have peace my body has a fighting chance
to not be so anxious so I have a
fighting chance to go do things that I
actually want to do I'm tired of waiting
for people
yeah and that will be where you find so
and so
and you will be the best version of
yourself when you all do meat
I know that's the worst I know it's the
worst
go pack my bags
bags you know what I mean
yeah all right so what if I did this
what if I did this
so you know I work with Dave Ramsey here
what if I gave you a year of Financial
Peace University and the every dollar
app to help you pay off your what you
owe would you do it
that would be amazing okay done if I
gave you my book own your past about
dealing with your childhood stuff so
that you can be a functioning adult
would you read it
absolutely done if I gave you three or
four sets of questions for humans so
that when you're going out and being
weird you could be like hey I got these
cards and they'll be they'll they'll
either go you're an idiot let's do this
which is awesome or they'll be like okay
and it'll give you a pass if I give them
to you we actually use them
I will level my weirdness for you
absolutely excellent
excellent
and then it's just gonna be I give you
some tools but you just have to go out
and be weird and take a risk and go make
friends and get a community and start
looking in your life for ways you can
not be surrounded by a bunch of clutter
and not be surrounded by nobody
yeah
and let's be honest that fear you have
at the end of it all that's real that's
real
yeah but it's more a symbol it's a
representation of the death of this
fantasy you've had since you were a very
little girl which isn't gonna have a
family
and I'm going to be at the epicenter
Mike you've probably already have a
picture in your head of
the Thanksgiving where one of your kids
brings home somebody the first time
I mean I did but now I'm almost 40.
oh so what now I'm just a crazy aunt
that's okay
I don't I I know if you got pregnant
right now they would treat you like
you're a thousand years old or whatever
but here's the deal yeah
um
I don't think you're done can I tell you
my mom's story have you heard me say
that on the show
uh bits and pieces
um I mean yes about her going back to
school 42.
yep and I'm trying to figure out a way
to surprise her in Oxford this summer
and I'm only saying that because this
show will be out by the time I'm gone
because she's doing her last year at
Oxford this summer at 73.
amazing I know but it's not weird she
just made some choices one little step
after another little step after another
little another little step
you get one shot at this tiny little
reckless Crazy Life we got
and you are worth so
much
are you in
I'm in I promise do it yes
all right if you will take a picture
of the people at your first weird little
dinner party that you're gonna throw
okay
send it into the show and we will post
it in the show notes we will all
celebrate you everyone Across America
will celebrate you for going to be weird
and look here's why it's important
because you're going to provide people a
picture of what it looks like to go out
and take a risk
it's going to dig a risk
because you know that being alone is
killing you
you know that putting up with abuse and
toxicity or whatever is going on in your
life and I'm not talking to you I'm
talking to everybody listening
oh
it's killing you
so try something different
you're worth so much more